[Music]
this
is star talk i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal
astrophysicist and today we're going to
talk about
puzzle solving specifically crossword
puzzle
solving the kind of puzzles that show up
all around the world
in newspapers magazines in in puzzle
books
that's what we're going to be talking
about chuck you're going to help me talk
about this
i was going to say in other words we we
just we just want people not to
see this show because
like how you going how you gonna do that
neil how are you gonna start this show
with
like and today we're talking crossword
puzzles click
you you're supposed to say today we're
talking the science of the fast and the
furious
all nine movies right okay oh here we go
oh here we go okay
and then we need to strike them i got a
new introduction ready
okay here we go this is star talk
today we're talking about what goes on
in the brain
when you're trying to solve a problem
you've never seen before
and we're gonna reach in and analyze
what happened ever
is that a little better that was great
wait okay see
now i'm listening and now all right
but of course neither of us have any
expertise in that we got to get someone
who is
one of the experts in the world on
creating the crossword puzzles and
solving them
and so we combed the world and we found
a 17 year old girl i think
soleil have you turned 18 yet i turned
18 in february yep
in february okay okay welcome to star
talks
thank you thank you you you are a
resident crossword puzzle expert
and and and we we chose you because
not that i had any special clairvoyance
on this but
you are the youngest person to ever get
a puzzle published a publisher in the
new york times is that correct did i
understand that
youngest woman to get one in the
youngest woman ever to get one okay
well i bet the youngest guy could not
have been that much younger i'm betting
yeah
how old was the youngest guy 13 13.
and and this was so late so his puzzle
sucked
it was all about transformers and juice
boxes
juice boxes and boobies
what like i think seven across was
boobies
all right so so the youngest woman ever
to get a course puzzle published in the
new york times
so i think this brought you a lot of
attention didn't it
yeah it did a lot of unexpected
attention definitely
okay but it was welcome i mean okay
unexpected but like
it wasn't bad i guess right i mean no of
course it was not bad it was not bad i
was just like
i only made a crossword puzzle i didn't
anticipate you know the today show
to ask about it okay or you didn't cure
cancer or something
right so how long have you been doing
crossword puzzles
i've been doing crossword puzzles
probably since i was like 10
but not not of the new york times
caliber uh people magazine
back with people magazine with my mom
damn she just dissed people magazine
damn
no not me yeah well man actually
she really didn't diss new york i mean
people magazine people magazine kind of
dissed people magazine by putting a
crossword puzzle
in people magazine what kind of
reasoning are you invoking i'm just
saying like if you're going up against
the new york times you shouldn't call
yourself
people magazine
[Laughter]
all right so so you so that you got
engaged in solving them
right so fine all right i can you know
throw it you know throw a stick and hit
20 people who solve
puzzles right but it's like another
subset
another sort of in the venn diagram
there's that smaller subset
who creates the puzzle so what pop
what possessed you to do such a thing
definitely a lot of boredom so i started
wanting to be able to make them wait
you're in school
you were supposed to you're learning in
school
and now you're saying you're bored okay
well uh
it was summer 2020 so it wasn't really
like i was doing much
um stuff oh covet summer cove it's
summer summer oh oh god i gotta gotta
got it okay go on
so you did something so instead of
binging uh you know the kardashians
you decided to wait a minute and so
wait so this was a relatively new
endeavor for you
to create a product create which okay
there are people who one puzzle
competitively
and two spend their entire freaking life
trying to create a crossword puzzle and
you're saying that
you got bored you were home from school
and so you damn okay
all right so so are you so okay
so i i think many people don't realize
that for many crossword puzzles
certainly the new york times course were
puzzled the black
boxes where their occlude does not land
is like laterally mirror symmetric
across the puzzle so it's rotational
symmetry you have
oh excuse me excuse me
excuse me damn
yeah okay sorry so it's rotationally
symmetric
yes rotationally symmetric i believe
it's 180 degrees
rotational symmetry um you can do mirror
symmetry if you'd like but
more classic is rotational okay so this
makes it even harder because it forces
how long
the answers must be right in
relationship to what else is going on in
the puzzle
right right okay yeah of course yeah
it's a puzzle with inside with within a
puzzle when you're trying to place the
black squares just because
depending on where you place the black
squares depending on what words you have
in different places
different patterns arise and so bad
black square placement could lead to a
terrible puzzle interesting or an
unsolvable puzzle
right right so now when you say that
when you talk about the placement of
black squares and the puzzle within the
puzzle
are you saying that to the consummate uh
uh puzzler or or or a crossword person
that uh they can look at your formation
and that will help them in the solving
of the puzzles
normally no when you're solving them it
wouldn't help but for a constructor
that's really
that's where the brain power comes in i
think
is is arranging those black squares to
make sure
that one you have a solvable puzzle and
two that you're creating as many
opportunities possible for you to have
uh words in those spaces
right plus and new york times and i'm
sure the london times as well
there's often a whole storyline going on
within the clues of the puzzle itself
right right a whole backstory on this
clue relates to that clue and it's the
third
word of a title that was in that clue
yeah and so
it's like all these little easter eggs
that are easter eggs and the puzzle
itself or the clues themselves
okay but soleil doesn't that mean like
you have to be older and
wiser and have life experience to put
all of this in the puzzle
she's like no you just have to know how
to read
that's what soleil is saying i mean i
mean kind of
you're right i i i don't think that you
have to be
or have any sort of particular large
subset of knowledge
um uh the way that crossword puzzle
constructing
works now is we we have software and you
put in word lists that a lot of people
end up coding
and um you know i could put in tick-tock
language into my crossword puzzle um
obviously the 80 year old won't be able
to solve it but
all of my friends will and yeah
okay so you can so you can tune the
crossword puzzle
to make it harder easy for whoever it is
you want to make it hard or easy for
exactly yep right okay so now okay
for the new york times when what would
you say is the hardest crossword puzzle
to do
on a consistent basis the saturday the
saturday is known as
the hearts puzzle okay of the week okay
okay so which puzzle did you
you did which puzzle i i constructed a
monday
but the saturday is the hardest to solve
so okay okay so you still have you still
have headroom here to grow
okay so so the monday is like the entry
level
okay and do they get progressively hard
during the week or is it just saturday
is the hardest and that's all there is
to it
they get progressively harder to solve
throughout the week and then sunday like
the famous sunday times puzzle it's just
the largest in size so rather than a 15
by 15
grid you have a 21 by 21 grid but it's
about wednesday difficulty
so that also means you have to have a
sizable vocabulary you have to have a
sizable
yes vocabulary but also wordless so
throughout the days or like weeks a lot
of crossword constructors you'll come
upon a new word or you're come upon a
new phrase
and you'll just add that into your word
list on your computer and that word list
will automatically update the software
in your um
that it's used to construct i think the
hardest part about
words and vocabulary when it comes to
crossword puzzles
is recognizing letter patterns so
there's obviously some letter patterns
that everyone knows
are more prevalent than others like tion
like everyone knows that's
quite common but when you're
constructing a puzzle
and you see e-a-c or you see
um uh like three vowels in a row
or something and you have like say like
a seven-letter
word you're going to be able to tell
more easily
um which which words will be able to fit
that
that's the type of pattern recognition
that you have to use as a constructor
i see and because there are fewer words
that will have that but you have to be
able to
you have to be armed and dangerous when
every time you see the because you could
be handed that set of
letters while you're constructing the
puzzle and then you can go straight to
your word
for it right right and the more you fill
it in
the more the puzzle itself helps you
right
you'd hope you'd hope yeah sometimes i
mean constructing a crossword puzzle
if you get stuck in one place you kind
of have to erase the entire corner and
restart um it's not really like a
because it's a dominant effect once one
word doesn't fit or write
it doesn't work oh right everything else
doesn't work around it so
okay so silly do you take pleasure in
this
is there some dopamine in your is it or
is it pleasure knowing that you made a
puzzle that other people can't solve
right like i guess i'm just asking why
you just like messing with old people
sitting around reading a newspaper
no there's definitely pleasure in it for
me um
i love puzzles of all types i
do a lot of science but i also read a
lot and i think
all of those different types of
endeavors are different types of puzzles
and i think
that this is just a different way to
stretch my brain and then about
making people frustrated and angry i
typically don't like to do that
um when i started solving i was 10
and crossword puzzle and i probably
moved on to new york times crossword
when i was about 13.
and new york times crossword puzzles are
not made for seventh and eighth graders
so most of the time i'd finish a puzzle
frustrated and
having to google everything because i
had no idea how to solve it and
i don't like making people feel stupid
and that's how i felt when i solved
them wow wow see you
that's nobody you never make a good
comedian
[Laughter]
that's the best feeling in the world is
making somebody realize how
stupid they are so
so you're you're graduating high school
basically so what do you what do you
want to major in
so i'm assuming i assumed you're going
to college yeah
yeah actually uh funny thing i'm i'm
going to harvard next year
i don't know exactly what i'm majoring
in but wait wait did i ask you where you
were going
no no you weren't and i know no i did
not ask i need to fix that i need to
stop doing that i did not ask you
where you were going okay okay let me
tell you this jokes
are so late so that you can remember
this how do you know somebody went to
harvard
when they tell you they went to harvard
it's like this don't worry they'll tell
you
okay but i was i was thinking about
their history and science program
and like doing a very it's prestigious
the history of science yeah
i'm really excited for that hopefully i
do that in like philosophy maybe
i'm not entirely sure mm-hmm all right
cool
did you get a scholarship do they give
scholarships to those schools not for
smarts
only if you're not they don't give
scholars for anything if a financial aid
scholarship yeah but not
not for athletics or or for being smart
no
right okay that ain't about that that's
wrong number one
it's wrong it is wrong you're right it's
wrong you are right
okay that ain't right at all all right
let me ask you another question
in a few minutes we have what um
are there other places you can apply
these skills
other than just making another crossword
puzzle
okay that's the answer yeah that's a
really
great that's a really great question
that i
don't have an answer to okay it's just
nice to know that if you have this
talent that it can spill out
and help you in other things that's all
maybe not the hard skills of
of creating a crossword puzzle but more
so the
the perseverance the try on error the
i don't know all the hard knocks the
lessons of it the lessons of it
rather than rather than the actual
putting black squares down because i
don't think you do that in real life so
okay so now i'll ask you like a few of
your favorite things so what's
the your the best clue you ever came up
with
the most clever one you're just really
proud of and you like you put it on the
wall
well the one that sticks out in my head
is uh
the answer was georgians and it was john
ossoff and raphael warnock for two
and it was right after the georgia
senate elections that that was just
timely and just like
i don't know i i like that i'm not super
punny or clever when it comes to my
because i find some puzzles go out of
their way to be funny and clever and
it's almost just annoying
they're just trying to show off that
they can run that way
it's sometimes annoying but also i just
genuinely cannot think that way i i
don't know how people do it
all the time so i mean i i just like the
uh
pop culture references the the things
that are
relevant to the present day okay that's
what we do and we try to do some pop
culture on the on this show
and and also now let me ask you this
before we go to pop culture
um 62 across
all right kick up to be
unruly and the answer is
a fuss now a fuss
itself is a word or a fuss as
in you're making a fuss as in you're
making a fuss
okay you cheated man wait wait a fuss is
one word
no it's yours but it's two words but
it's
you you tricked me i thought it was a
word it's allowed to
we're allowed to trick you
oh okay oh that's cold oh that's
cold-blooded man
well two-word answers are fine
you're right because you can have
compound words or actual just
two words or titles or you could have a
title it could so you're absolutely
right
you will play that way you're gonna play
that way all right yeah
you you yeah i tell you what you're
doing you kick sand in my eyes
all right well so this this is great and
i'm i'm just i'm delighted to have you
on the show here
and to showcase this and in the next two
segments we're going to just sort of get
inside the puzzle solving brain
and find out what what it's doing for us
that and why is it there at all
because think about it you know do other
animals solve crossword puzzles i don't
think so
i don't know man i i was i've seen a
couple like
orangutans sitting around but they were
only doing the people magazine
very cool all right so lay we got to
call it quits there but it's been a
delight to have you and
good luck at school excuse me good luck
at harvard
and you sir have the boorish manners of
a yearly just now
so uh all right and and work hard and
study hard and
we'll catch you on the other side yeah
and
uh be uh be great to have you back on if
you find some other sort of maybe you'll
invent a new kind of puzzle i love that
when that happens
and it becomes all the rage or just keep
it
better yet why don't you just take uh
make an astrophysics star talk
puzzle for us and then we'll get the new
york times to
put it in the new york times maybe i
should you just want her to work for
free
chuck what do you do oh by the way
wait wait wait i i think i know the
answer to this but i have to ask can you
make a living writing crossword puzzle
yes you can you can't you can't
yeah the new york times and the new
yorker honestly they have uh
associate games editors and puzzle
editors so you could be a
you could be a puzzle editor no no no
i'm talking okay but if you just
write puzzles and submit them well i
mean
hmm i guess at the new yorker that's
kind of how it works
like they have like kind of staff
writers and they don't have
anyone else so they're staff their staff
okay
but if you just if you just randomly
come up with one and throw it in
you're not paying rent off of that money
no you're not paying rent off that money
you do get paid but you're not paying
right off okay
all right okay all right all right
people magazine is playing really well
all right so uh soleil said see it
saint sayer saints here yeah saint sear
uh
good luck sometimes you need a little
bit of that too and
we like to keep you on on our radar
because we're going to find out if you
you know when you're beyond college
uh we will have high expectations for
you oh that is see the problem is you
start low then anything you
achieve is good but now really you can
only disappoint people i just that's
right i'm
sorry i'm gonna tell you this uh soleil
whatever you do don't become a comic
because
it's not gonna go well for you people
gonna be mad yeah
people will be seriously upset see when
i was your
age i was a total failure so i became a
stand-up comic
and they're like he's moderately
successful their reference point was so
low
[Laughter]
all right when we return we're gonna
sort of get inside the head of puzzle
makers of course with the help of
friend of star talk professor heather
berlin
when we return we're back
star talk cosmic query's puzzle edition
what a first segment that was chuck just
yes
it gives us hope for the future nothing
gives me hope for the future
nothing gives you nothing but try to
help a little bit but it did help it did
help
it did help and what we want to try to
do is get to the bottom of
what's going on in the mind of somebody
who not only
does puzzles but even has the has the
interest and the ability to create them
in the first place right that's that's a
subset of everyone presumably
who does puzzles and we we are delighted
to always be in arms reach
of our resident neuroscientist heather
berlin heather welcome back to star talk
yeah yeah pleasure your psychologist
and professor of psychiatry at the icon
school of medicine
at mount sinai right here in new york
city and it's always good to have you
because you you take us places that
you know we think you know everyone
likes to think they understand their own
brain
no they don't they don't
yes you are let me tell you something
you are much more stupid than your brain
[Laughter]
you are correct yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so so heather
um before we get to our our our
uh listeners questions about solving
crossword puzzles
could you just set it up for us why does
anyone want to solve a puzzle how does
that have any value to what it is
to be human interesting yeah you know it
actually it takes us back to our kind of
hunter gatherer
roots right it's it's about searching
it's the hunt
to find something to something that you
value at the end of the hunt
exactly so you pick up clues along the
way
you know our brains evolved to try to um
figure out where the reward is right
okay i know that if i see
you know the branches hanging this way
that maybe means there's an animal
behind it and so
we learned how to figure out pick up on
these cues to get the reward at the end
if a then b then c then maybe d and d is
right okay but people are doing this and
when you finish the crossword puzzle
there isn't a biscuit that comes out of
the bag
there isn't some you know where is what
is
the reward it can't just be i
solved it that doesn't improve your
survivability
because we've we're feeding the dolphin
when it performs for us
in the you know you're throwing at the
fish and you're throwing and even the
dogs at the
at the dog show right uh they're feeding
them
any dog any any animal doing tricks you
feed them so yeah by the way
the new york times just called neil and
they said thank you
from now on all crosswords will come
with a little biscuit
at the end somehow our crossword and
patronage has gone up five thousand
percent
yeah so i mean there are these there are
different kinds of rewards right they're
primary
reinforcers we call them which is you
know food or water
um or sex for that matter um but then
we've evolved these secondary
reinforcers
so the same neural system that gives us
that
hit of dopamine that gives us a reward
when we eat something sweet let's say
has in a way been hijacked so now you're
getting that same reward the same neural
pathway is triggered when you solve a
problem
um whether you get a sweet treat at the
end or not
it becomes irrelevant because it's now a
secondary reinforcer you're reinforced
just in the fact of having solved
something
wow okay so so
our our reward system
is really uh use the term what carjacked
what kind of jacks was it
hijacked i thought of carjacking so
funny
[Laughter]
so what you're saying is things that
were in some way did serve to get us
food
food was primary but there's secondary
pleasures or rewards coming to the brain
and that's what we're feeding today
because obviously
there's food everywhere right so that's
food is not the reward anymore
yeah and in a way it it can be come
addictive
just like drugs of addiction it's that
same neural pathway that you
crave solving problems which is a good
thing
let's see what our fan base just what
questions they have about puzzles
and so we're already kind of a notch up
because i think not everyone does
puzzles so maybe
this might be like slightly more erudite
than what we're normally doing here but
let's find out
chuck what do you have all right let's
start things off with um
this is andrew
one or the other or stop like tope uh
he says hello dr tyson hello dr berlin
and dr
comedy very funny
very funny andrew uh as always chuck if
you can pronounce my last name correctly
the first time i'll double my patreon
membership immediately
whoa you all
oh man wait now he tells you after after
i should have read this scene i don't
get i don't read these questions
beforehand people
and now you know for a fact that i don't
read these questions beforehand
because damn it damn we just lost out on
that one right
oh wait how does he spell his last name
uh it's s-t-a-u-p-e so stop a stop no i
would say
stop stop stop that's my guess
okay so stout see like to me i figure
cause it looks like stoop but you know i
don't think that
it i don't think anybody has like a
yiddish last name
okay all right so anyway he says this
he says uh we all know the human brain
is especially hard
wired for problem solving above and
beyond many species living today however
i'm wondering
if you or other scientists have
speculation on how
as to how far back in homo sapiens
history these earlier hominids could
have had these various puzzles and
games that modern humans do
daily would it be ten thousand years
fifty thousand years a hundred thousand
years or more
interesting but so a deeper question
there is is this a primate thing
in general or you know i guess lions are
solving puzzles when they want to
sneak up on their antelope or whatever
they're chasing the zebra
right i guess they do a little bit of
that but
i think we're thinking higher level
problem solving aren't we in this
exercise yeah he's also talking about
for pleasure
not for not just survival right
you um it's a good question it depends
on on you know how you define
games right like obviously they're not
going to have the modern types of games
that we've developed now as our
prefrontal cortexes have evolved um
over the last couple of hundred thousand
years
but even you know five hundred thousand
years wait you don't you don't you don't
think they have
grand theft auto back then
video games they didn't right gram theft
chariot
i mean they were solving problems even
you know there's records of
um very sophisticated um axes that were
found
that were hand carved you know 500 000
years ago um and in order to do that you
really had to use a lot of problem
solving skills so
you can go as far back as that you can
think about there's a whole theory
that the brain developed because of our
social interactions and having to solve
problems in in relating to other
people and that goes very very far back
as well
so you know it's hard to say whether
they were playing games for fun
per se but they certainly were
developing the problem solving
tool kit that is then needed to play the
games that we now play for fun
uh whether they were getting pleasure
out of the problem-solving i'm going to
assume
yes they were because or else they
wouldn't keep doing it right they kept
doing it because they were either
getting rewards at the end killing an
animal
um or social positive feedback uh and
over time it
became reinforcing in and of itself
right
wow that's pretty cool i mean that makes
sense
yeah you know the thing is that pleasure
back then i mean when you go far enough
back in
our human history pleasure is
surviving yeah anything that doesn't
kill you right pleasure
you know so the whole night
the whole idea of you know the sunday
afternoon
crossword puzzle i don't i don't think
you had that
it's like drug the saber tooth only bit
six of my fingers off
but that's the whole i mean the whole
premise is that these systems these
neural systems that evolve to help us
survive
and to get pleasure out of doing the
things that help us survive
are now we're kind of hacking into them
um
by you know creating these games that
hack into the systems the original
purpose of which
was to survive i think that's the key
point there yeah yeah
okay all right chuck what else you got
all right let's move on to mike
bertuccio
and he says this hi my girlfriend loves
all kinds of puzzles
jigsaws crosswords you name it but hates
playing
board games or card games to me
puzzles and board games offer similar
challenges and
engagement why are some people really
into puzzles
and not other kinds of mind challenging
pastimes well i wonder heather puzzles
are very solo right whereas board games
you're competing against someone else
so maybe that's the difference is that
what do you face
yeah also i mean okay it depends on what
the board game is
or the card game is but a lot of board
games and i know this because i have
young children and i'm
forced to play board games quite often
is that it's really
a bit of luck that's involved you know
do you pick the right card do you roll
the right number of dice
so it's less about problem solving you
know and and
you don't have to really actively
cognitively engage use your memory you
know when you're doing a crossword
puzzle you're having to engage your
memory and all these associations
between words and ideas
board games don't challenge you in that
same way a lot of it is just did you
roll the right number did you pick the
right card
same thing with playing cards you know
are you lucky with the hand you were
dealt
and so it's more about luck than it is
about actually
cognitive skill in in many cases okay so
this dude's
girlfriend is smarter than he even
thought
because she she wants to be in total
control over all of what's going on
and do it with her mind and not rely on
the randomness of dice
that's yeah so yes you're putting it at
a higher level
that's what it sounds like higher
cognitively it's more cognitively
demanding again depending on you know
there are some
card games yeah i was going to say but
bridge is a very uh is a game of
strategy
and poker uh is really for those who
play it
well it's really about knowing the
percentages of the hands
so what you're doing is extrapolating
the percentage that you might win
if you're a good poker player but then
also using human nature
in terms of bluffing and knowing your
opponent so
so it's a different i would say it's a
different skill set
than the ones that are used for these
problem-solving kinds of um
puzzles different kinds of skills so i
don't i i hesitate to say one is higher
than the other it's just different and
some people prefer one over the other
so there'll be individual differences in
terms of preferences okay but it's so
it's sensible that there's a divide
between these two
kinds of entertainment okay interesting
wow i never thought of it that way mike
uh the real answer is
your girlfriend is right
[Laughter]
period of sentence do you need anything
else i don't think so
okay
all right here we go this is a jocelyn
uh
uh uh salias nope
sales okay forget it
all right sally us okay there you go um
she says hello dr tyson hello dr berlin
and okay of course chuck jesus christ
what is up with you people
what the hell is happening we love you
chuck we love you chuck
all right we love you she says my
question is
why is it easier to solve number of
puzzles like sudoku
than it is to find that one jigsaw piece
you've been searching for
that usually ends up being right in
front of your face
are our brains just hardwired for
numbers
also why does solving puzzles have a
calming effect oh i like that
so is heather one is is a jigsaw puzzle
visual and then sudoku is just
mathematical is that
is it that simple to say well there's
two things
one is again using different aspects of
your brain and of cognition so one is
visual spatial solving puzzles and when
we look at
we can do cognitive tests or iq tests we
find that some people are
really have a skill set where they're
really good at visual spatial processing
and maybe they're not so good at
working with with numbers um but so
they're two different skill sets and the
thing with
the puzzle pieces is that there's
something that's called um
inattentional blindness so sometimes
there are things that are in your
environment that are right in front of
your face but
you um your your attention you're not
paying attention to them because they're
kind of blending in with everything else
yeah so there's nothing distinctive
about that particular piece that's going
to make it highlighted above the rest of
the thesis so in a way you're blind to
it it's
it's the nose it's the nose blindness of
your eyes
yes yes you perpetuate exactly like if
there's a really horrible smell in the
room
eventually you don't smell it anymore
over time your brain habituates and the
same thing with
you have the same environment all the
time or like you know your spouse after
a while you just
don't see them at all you just don't see
them
there you go did i get it did i get a
new sofa oh no
that's my wife so
it sounds like heather could use some
counseling too at the end of this
session
don't tell my husband but the other
thing i wanted to say is that yes
puzzles can have a very calming effect
that's why people tend to go to these
things like on their phones you know
like candy crush or whatever is that
it it's a kind of repetitive it's very
internally focused you don't need any
external
you know you can just kind of play
around in your mind and for some people
that repetitive
way of thinking can be very relaxing for
them plus in gamers i've spoken to who
write these things it's apparently very
important to have a reward system
built in where whatever is however small
the accomplishment is
you get that sort of gold star like what
you had in elementary school
and then that accumulates so that you're
always coming back back to it
so but i i can't claim that it's always
calming when i see people getting a
little
getting sort of excited or anxious
about going back in for that next level
so
it's not like i think no i think things
like like um
making puzzles those kinds of things
where it's less about competition
and where you're getting the adrenaline
and excitement and it's more about just
solving
solving things solving puzzles solving
the crossword
and the games it's a dif it's a
different kind of thing it is more about
the reward and the unexpected reward and
you keep trying to go for it it's more
to do like with gambling um than it is
to do with that kind of calming effect
got it got it well guys we got to take a
quick break but when we come back
more of cosmic query's puzzle edition
with our our our resident
psychologist we call her psychologists
right that's what neuroscientists
no no neuropsychologist without with a
resident neuroscientist i like that
uh heather berlin we'll be right back
we're back
uh heather berlin you're helping us
figure out the brain and puzzle solving
and heather you you have a a twitter
account heather berlin i think right
heather underscore berlin don't forget
the underscore i know you hate the
understanding i hate
underscores what can we do about that
they're evil
it's an underscore because there's not
underscoring anything it's just they're
all by itself it's underscoring a blank
space
right you know what it's underscoring
it's underscoring the fact that there
was another
another i have the land that didn't
allow me to use that twitter
oh that's underscoring that you are not
the first
heather berlin on social media hi chuck
chuck nice comic tweeting there yes
thank you so yes so you've got q a for
us let's let's do it
let's get right back into it here we go
uh this is
robert weaver and robert says uh to the
incredibly funny and smart chuck nice
thanks for taking my question
you're trying to make up
all right this is what robert says
robert says this are we doing
any studies about puzzle puzzles
solving addictions i am at level 7175 of
candy crush i always seem to flip to it
when i'm bored i love sudoku and
jigsaw puzzles some people don't seem to
care i also like to gamble smoke
cigarettes
so is there any uh anything to puzzles
puzzle solving and addiction uh yes
absolutely so
like we were saying before the reward
system it's it's when we
we have an unexpected reward that's
gonna hit you're not sure when it's
going to come
that causes you to keep coming back and
back and back again
um to sort of try to find when am i
going to get my hit and so some of these
games i mean the game makers like of
candy crush
they studied psychology they understand
what they're doing and they've they've
created
they hire people like you they hire
people that you get inside our head okay
exactly exactly and so they've created
the games with a reward
schedule that will keep us coming back
for more so it all and it's
especially for people who already have
um addiction issues in other domains
whether it's with drugs and alcohol
or gambling um they're much more prone
to get kind of sucked
into these games and and find themselves
doing it for hours and hours and not
being able to stop
is there correlation between getting
addicted to one thing and getting
addicted to something else i mean is
there an addiction center
that has the susceptibility there is i
wouldn't say
um like there's not like an addictive
type of personality but yes we tend to
see
um addiction can cut across different
domains that's what i was wondering
yeah yeah exactly and what we found
actually in some studies that that we've
done in my lab is that
people who are let's say addicted to
gambling they actually the nucleus
accumbens the reward center of the brain
that receives that hit of dopamine
um when you take a person without
addiction and you say you're about to
get a reward they start getting
activation in that area
people who have gambling problems they
have less activation they need
more stimulation to get the same high so
that's why some people can resist it
that's why someone can resist it
oh my god right right but others they
need that stimulation just to feel like
another person might just feel naturally
uh so
so rather that it's a kind of under
activation and they're searching for
more to get to
get the same high that the average
person might get with something way less
intense
wow so we're just sacks of chemistry
that's all you're telling us man that's
pretty
much sorry guys
sorry to break it to you you are your
brain yeah all right
all right chuck give me some more all
right this is andrew
um jendro who says this and by the way
they're all patreon members everybody
that's what we're doing now yeah that
week
if you're listening and you want to send
us a question
uh that we will read over the air please
uh
sign up and support us at patreon.com
star talk radio mm-hmm
all right because that's where we get
all of our our inquiries from now
and by the way you said read it over the
air even if earth had no air since we
use electromagnetic signals
it would still get transmitted so okay
oh no good to know i'm just looking
heather heather's making a note of that
the on the air is just [ __ ] it has
nothing to do with the air
it has to do with the space time
continuum i just thought i'd slip that
in
but if we didn't have air no one would
be here to receive the message every
sentence
all right it says uh dr tyson dr berlin
what do we know
about how puzzles and challenges keep
our minds
sharp as we age oh i like that yeah
heather what's up with that
if i want to keep my mind as healthy as
possible which puzzles
in particular should i be doing yeah
and is it true at all to begin with
right you know the research is mixed
um some studies show that yes it helps
stave off cognitive decline
others show that it doesn't really make
much of a difference so it's been
it's been sort of controversy within the
literature however
what we do know is that it has to do
with novelty
so if you've been doing crossroad
puzzles your whole life
your brain kind of habituates and you're
not it's not helping that much
as you age but it's about changing it up
switch to do
a different kind of mental activity
learn an instrument
learn a language do something completely
foreign
exactly because the thing with dopamine
it's not just about a reward it's about
um motivation right and and the more
novel something is the more motivated
you are and the more
you're going to keep your brain active
and healthy and excited to kind of keep
learning
so it's about not just doing a puzzle
itself
but about changing the cognitive task
you're doing okay
and that can help stave off aging yes
all right cool go ahead keep coming
chuck we got time for a few more
all right here we go this is uh uh
frederick johansson
who says hello dr tyson dr berlin and mr
nice guy
uh okay i'll take that we'll take that
we'll take that
okay frederick he says uh how come
it seems some puzzles such as the
rubik's cube
seem nearly impossible to solve when
they are first released
but after a while people seem to be able
to solve them within seconds blindfolded
um okay i think there there's a lot
to unpack here but one thing i do want
to say about puzzles as
as a side note before i get into rubik's
cubes is that a lot of them i got one
back here
i got one i think are you going to solve
it for us hang on
is that what comes next what we what we
know about solving puzzles is that the
majority of what's happening is
happening unconsciously
right so we we try to solve it
consciously and then
because our unconscious has a much
larger capacity can process many more
variables
um most of uh problem solving is
implicit or happening unconsciously
and we know that from two interesting
studies one is they gave people a
problem to solve
um the answer wasn't obvious you kind of
had to think outside the box and people
weren't able to do it
then they use tms which is a type of
magnetic stimulation it's called trans
transcranial magnetic stimulation to
stimulate the
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex which in
a way released our
our kind of constraints in our brain
normally things are constrained it
released the constraints and suddenly
people were able to solve the problem
because it allowed them to access these
unconscious processes
the really fascinating stuff and the
other study that's related to that is
that they had people
try to solve a problem again with a
solution that was outside the box they
couldn't do it then they either had them
sleep for eight hours
or kept them awake for eight hours and
after which the people who slept 60
of them could now find the shortcut and
only 23
of the other group so again the
unconscious brain is processing so with
the rubik's cube
you know i think over time people not
only did they consciously learn the
algorithms and
figure out how to solve them but after
practicing and doing it over and over
again the unconscious
again was picking up on cues and
figuring out how to solve it maybe even
faster than the conscious mind
okay so i think there's your build up i
think there's a thread in that question
unstated that there is a researcher
named rupert sheldrake
in the uk oh i know him yeah who is
certain
that there's some kind of consciousness
field and that
that we all tap into and as more people
solve it that enriches the consciousness
field
such that it's easier for you coming
later in the day than it was for those
who started it earlier in the day and he
based that off of the
the very real statements that people
make
solving the london times crossword
puzzle uh by the end
they say oh by the end of the day i was
really good at it but early on
i wasn't and so he's making this
assertion but i always wondered
you know maybe just you're more awake at
three in the afternoon than you were
at nine in the morning and there might
be other explanations for that than a
consciousness field that defies
all experimental measures of the laws of
physics right
i agree so i'm gonna go with that too
i'm gonna go with that instead of the
consciousness field
okay all right you're going with that
thank you and by the way
uh uh vadim feskin because you answered
his question but i
i would just want to read it uh he says
hello neil chuck heather i have a
question about problem-solving
phenomenon that happens when you get
stuck on a problem
and do some other non-brain uh intensive
activity
there it is and you happen to arrive at
the answer
what's happening so i just wanted to
read that because you answered his
question
in the process of answering this rubik's
cube question as well exactly the thing
is when you're trying to solve a problem
take in all the information distract
yourself do something else let your
unconscious work on it and then you'll
come up with these aha moments
or walk into one of your magnetic
chambers that you have in your home that
you put your husband through
every day
put that magnet in the zapper right on
both sides
and then all of a sudden you won't even
care what the problem is you'll just go
take out the garbage
yeah heather has the most obedient
husband i have ever seen in my life
our little secret that's a little secret
we won't tell anybody
okay all right chuck time for a few more
times
uh this is uh jorah's petrovic who says
this
uh hello dr tyson dr berlin i would like
to ask you
how different is the location of brain
activity depending on the type of puzzle
the person is actually
i like that are there any nodes in
quotations of
problem solving which might light up and
in our
mri or other scans no matter what the
nature visual numerical linguistical
uh of the problem i love it yeah heather
yes yes yeah so no matter what the
problem is and of course if it's
linguistic you're going to get language
areas or visual spatial get visual areas
but
outside of those differences you're
always going to get activation in the
prefrontal cortex when you're doing
problem solving and that's
called the it's involved in executive
function of the brain it's kind of like
the conductor of the orchestra
and we see that always when somebody is
solving a problem no matter what the
problem in what domain
you get prefrontal cortex activation and
that's why people have lesions in the
prefrontal cortex or brain damage
uh it can affect their problem-solving
skills um
but this is other really interesting
case they can still solve problems in
some cases so this one patient
hm he had damage to his hippocampus the
memory part of his brain
and he would try to they would have him
solve these crossword puzzles he
wouldn't remember doing them
at all um but each day he would do them
he would get better and better at them
so his prefrontal cortex was intact but
his memory system was broken down so he
can't remember
doing the puzzles yet he kept getting
better at solving them so the
problem-solving part of the brain
is still doing its work whether you're
consciously aware of it or not
so he was not he was not solving the
puzzle from memory is what you're saying
he was resolving it every time
yeah and get and getting better as if
he's getting better right that's amazing
yeah that's really cool yeah hm cool
cool subject
yeah and remind me what the hippocampus
does memory
long-term memory consolidation so he had
no he lost his long-term memory but he
could still get better at implicit tasks
like
solving problems because i told chuck
before in my day
i was a big man on the hippocampus no
i just i just want to say i don't mean
to brag or anything but
in my day oh my god
there can't be that many brain jokes
okay that hurt that that hurt every lobe
in my brain there's got to be like a
finite number of brain jokes that exist
you know this this reminds me one of my
favorite shows on national geographic
um is brain games where every show they
they take you to some uh curious part of
how we function as humans
um and what's going on my favorite show
too oh oh oh
oh but i bet i think i know why it's
your favorite show because we
just learned on star talk that
chuck nice our very own we're taking
ownership for you
our own chuck knight is the new host of
brain games
[Applause]
so congratulations chuck thanks man yes
and we knew you when i just want to say
well you'll still know me then
yeah heather needs a big thank you on
that one chuck
yeah without a doubt so so when does it
air when does it kick in
uh fourth quarter of this year so look
for it later on in the year guys
the fall 2021. uh fall 2021.
we're looking at that towards the end of
this year excellent how many episodes
are there in the
and when it drops thus far uh well there
should be 20
but uh oh so it's gonna go the whole
year so it's the full it looks like
it's the fall into the spring okay so um
and if it if it doesn't then we will
know that chuck is no longer the host
if it cancels and everything if you see
less than 20 episodes
it did even worse
[Laughter]
all right we all look forward to that uh
uh yeah that's one of my favorite
shows on natural geographic after cosmos
of course just
i'm gonna say well yes of course uh how
could you not
so uh guys thanks for being on star talk
and helping make sense of this
puzzle solving centers of our brain and
it was a delight to have
solei sincere on and that first episode
in that first segment
and i look forward to having her back
maybe she would have solved problems
that we have created and have yet to
solve going forward
the first one could be hey when are you
coming back
okay that would be easy compared to
other things we confront but anyhow
she's the future
and that gives me confidence that uh
civilization will not go extinct all
right uh heather always good to have you
chuck uh we're looking looking forward
to your brain games i've been neil
degrasse tyson
keep looking up
[Music]
you